hello and welcome to sophie ridge on
sunday
sometimes the most frank and outspoken
interviews are with people who are no
longer on the political front line
and according to the former prime
minister tony blair politicians have
been playing fast and loose with the
northern ireland peace process
and no responsible mp could consider
leaving the eu
without a deal when i spoke to him he
also had quite a lot to say about the
way the labour leadership have dealt
with anti-semitism
that's all coming up and in a rare break
from brexit news will be looking
at the impact that social media is
having on society and what more can be
done
to protect vulnerable young people
in just a few moments we'll kick off the
show with my interview with tony blair
plus
chief secretary to the treasury and
social media star liz truss will be here
in the studio
labour's cello health secretary jonathan
ashworth will also be here
and as we continue to reach for voices
outside westminster
we'll speak to the director general of
the cbi carolyn fairbairn
now the campaign for a second referendum
took a big blow this week when jeremy
corbyn sent out his proposals for brexit
so when i sat down with tony blair
yesterday one of the faces
of the people's vote campaign i started
by asking if this was the week
that his dream of a second brexit
referendum died
no i i think the question of where we
we go in the future now is very open um
i actually thought his letter was
helpful in one sense
because the underlying
point in his letter was you have to
decide what type of brexit you want
before you leave
and this to me is the absolute clear
thing
i've never thought that you would get to
another referendum
going directly to it you'll get to it
when people see what the true brexit
alternatives are
and the truth is there are two you can
have a soft brexit which is really what
jeremy corbyn's suggesting
or you can have the hard brexit that
boris johnson and
nigel farage and other people want and
what i've really been saying all the way
through this process is you've got to
decide
which of those brexits you want before
you leave
otherwise you're going to leave without
clarity and if you leave without clarity
no clarity no closure the argument just
goes on and by then you'll have left
you'll have paid your money up front
you'll have given up your negotiating
leverage
and for the country to do that as
theresa may wants to do to leave without
knowing what brexit you get
this would be in my view you know an
incredibly foolish thing for the country
to do it's got to know
where we're heading before we leave i
just don't understand how you get to a
second referendum because you can't get
to there without the
support of the leader of the opposition
i can't see how that happens
and if you look at what he's saying in
this letter our first priority must be a
deal that's best for jobs and living
standards
and he's talking about the aim of
securing a sensible agreement i mean
this does not sound like a man who is
about to back a second referendum that
sounds like a man who wants a brexit
deal to pass the house of commons yeah
no i think you're absolutely right that
is what he wants
um but here's the thing i think theresa
may will reject that letter
indeed in a sense already has and the
soft brexit
that he's proposing once you start to
focus on that
okay supposing supposing parliament as
it should do
puts before parliament for a vote
the different brexit options because
you've essentially got two you've got a
soft brexit option which is what jeremy
corbyn's suggesting
that keeps you in a position more or
less like norway is at the moment
or you have a harder brexit option you
go out of the
trading system of the european union you
have a free trade agreement like canada
so you've got soft versus hard
once you actually get to deciding which
of those propositions you want
it's at that point that my suspicion is
ultimately
there'll be no support for either of
them and then you get to another
referendum
and you by the way you may get to
another referendum
in order to say to the country look now
we have a firm brexit deal
do you prefer that to staying if we do
leave
on march the 29th is that it or is there
possibility we might
rejoin i i think look there's some
people think you know you can leave in
the march
29th then you go into a long transition
period maybe you try and
rejoin during that time i i think that's
highly unlikely
um i think what will happen once you
leave is you're out
and that will be it for a generation at
least to coin a phrase from
donald tusk do you think there's a
special place in hell for a labour party
that facilitates brexit
well i don't think it's wise for the
labour party to facilitate
brexit because i don't think it's in the
interest of the country
and you know one of the things i find
most curious at one level although i
kind of get it at another level is when
i talk to labour mps and leave
constituencies who are backing brexit
and you will say to them okay
i know all the problems you've got in
your constituencies um
high levels of unemployment poor levels
of education poor infrastructure
lack of investment how do you think
brexit is going to make these problems
better and they will usually say i don't
think they're going to make them better
but the people voted for it and
therefore i feel i've got to vote for it
too
darth husk said this week that today
there's no political force and no
effective leadership for remain and he's
right isn't he there's a problem isn't
that that the face of the people's vote
is yourself it's jacromuna it's the pr
boss roland rudd live from davos i mean
you're not really doing much to
challenge the perception that this is a
movement from
the metropolitan liberal elite you know
this is an argument we've just got to be
really robust about
i mean 60 million million people voted
to remain i mean they're not all members
of the metropolitan elite and by the way
they're
met members of the metropolitan elite on
the other side of the debate and very
wealthy people on the other side of the
debate
this is a this is a nonsense the
question is what's in the interest of
the country
and the country voted to leave but it
didn't vote as to what form of brexit
and it's a bit it's a bit like having a
general election where the question is
do you like the government
if that was the question very few
governments will get re-elected
governments get re-elected when it's
do you like the government or do you
prefer the opposition and
this is why what is important is that
before we leave we get the clarity
and for the british people you know i'm
i'm intensely aware from the
conversations that i've had i've had
with people
you know there is a a degree of alarm
boredom
resignation over brexit most people
probably think look we voted for it just
get on with it
and this is of course where a
parliamentary democracy matters because
really what's happening is once
parliament studies it it's saying
well hang on it's not just a question of
getting on to it on with it do you want
a soft brexit or do you want to harm
brexit
and and this this essential dilemma
is the thing that has made this
negotiation
so extraordinary over the last 30 months
because essentially the government
because the cabinet can't agree
and the government can't agree they've
never made that choice
i want to talk to you about ireland as
well because you were of course involved
in the good friday agreement and
you understand more than most the
sensitivities in ireland and northern
ireland
so from your perspective if we have a no
deal brexit
will there be a hard border yes for sure
if we have no deal brexit it's a i mean
no one could responsibly propose this
uh it's it would be economically very
very dangerous for britain
and for the peace process in ireland
it would potentially be devastating you
would have a hard border
very hard border i mean no deal brexit
means a really hard border between north
and south in ireland
it's contrary to the good friday
agreement
and it will cause an enormous fission
within the united kingdom what would the
impact of that hard border be
well the impact will be that the thing
that has been in existence since
almost 100 years of the republic of
islands
you know um creation as a as a
as an independent state that border
that's been open
for that length of time and when britain
and ireland have always been in the same
relationship to europe as each other
that will end
you'll end up with real problems at the
border
huge economic problems south and north
and
i mean a very very bitter atmosphere no
this
nobody responsible could propose a a no
deal brexit and that's why i think
even if there isn't a parliamentary
majority at the moment for a particular
form of brexit or indeed for another
referendum
there's definitely a parliamentary
majority against no deal and i i really
do believe there are
people within the cabinet who are
sufficiently
serious and responsible not to allow
that to happen do you think that some
politicians are playing faster loose
than with the
peace process well i think they've been
paying playing fast and
loose with it from the very beginning i
mean those people who who cheerfully
say that you can put the united
kingdom and the republic of ireland in a
completely different relationship
with europe in trading terms and it make
no difference
to the economy of the north of ireland i
mean i i don't know what basis they
possibly say that i'm keen to talk to
you about the labour party as well
because several mps have been expressing
uh their unhappiness with the way the
party's been dealing with
allegations of anti-semitism and this
week jenny formby the general secretary
said it's impossible
to completely eradicate anti-semitism
from the party
is she right and does the left have a
blind spot when it comes to
anti-semitism
no and yes of course we should eradicate
anti-semitism from the labour party
i mean we're supposed to be a
progressive political party
how how can we how can we say it's
tolerable to have a
certain level of anti-semitism in the
party will be
say more generally it's tolerable to
have a a
a level of racism within the labor party
no we'd say i mean of course you can't
have that
and you know yes it's a it's
the the there are parts of the left
whole of the left
but there are parts of the left that do
have a problem with anti-semitism
and you see this in their attitudes to
to the state of israel
you can make all sorts of criticisms of
the state of israel but their
continual focusing on israel all the
time
you know over over a long period
you're left with the feeling that
they're in a sense targeting it because
it is a jewish state has the leadership
been robust enough on this
no it's not been robust enough of it and
and you know it's
the fact that someone like luciano
berger who's a you know
smart capable active member of
parliament doing her best for her
constituents the fact that she should
even be subject to a no-confidence
motion with this type of allegations
swirling around is is
shameful for the labour party i mean
should that constituency party be
suspended as
tom watson has called for well i think
what tom's saying is absolutely right
i'm
back i'm 100 on it i mean look it's if
he can you imagine that when i was
leader of everybody having a
conversation with me about whether
anti-semitism was in the labor party or
not i would have thought
you know we wouldn't even have that
conversation and there is i'm afraid
there is a kind of nascent alliance
between
what i would call bits of the sort of
islamist type of politics and and the
left and you can see this not just here
in the uk you can see it across europe
and it's you know yes it it gives rise
to anti-semitism it's not
it's not your traditional anti-semitism
of the old kind of
right-wing nature and you know not
wanting jewish people in golf clubs and
that type of thing
but it's every bit as pernicious and
you know to have a situation where
you've got labour mps
worried because they happen to be jewish
i mean
i'm keen to talk to you about foreign
affairs as well and we're close to the
anniversary of the
iranian revolution how do you think the
west should be dealing with iran today
if you look at the 40 years of the
iranian revolution
what's interesting and what my institute
has been doing
kind of expresses this is that
that ideology you know is still
very powerful i think it's more sensible
to view iran as a an ideology with a
state than a state with an ideology
and they've been exporting it around the
region for 40 years it's probably you
know the
policies of the iranian regime i think
are probably the most single most
destabilizing
um um
you know have this most destabilizing
consequence on the middle east
of anything that's happening today and i
think that the
this issue of how we deal with iran you
know we've kind of oscillated between
containment and confrontation
and what we need i think is a policy in
the west today in dealing with iran
which accepts the ideology hasn't
changed which accepts the nature of the
regime
and which where they're using hard power
confronts it and where they're using
soft power contains it and exposes it so
what what does that mean though what how
do we do that i mean
are you talking about keeping military
intervention on the table what do you
want to see i don't think you should
take any option off the table but
i mean obviously the best thing that
could happen is that this peaceful
change within iran because
the iranian people are educated people
they're people who want to be connected
with the world
if there was a free and fair election
iran i doubt very much whether the
regime would stand any chance of winning
it
um so that's what we
we hope for but in the meantime you've
got to push back you know you could this
is why
i i regret the decision the americans
took in relation to
to syria i think it's extremely
important that we support the new
leadership in iraq
uh which basically wants to assert the
independence of their country and should
be
do you worry that some of this retreat
some of this isolationism it's because
both the uk and the us have been
effectively scarred from iraq
well i mean yes of course it's a it's a
question for us but we should
we should also think you know today's
circumstances are completely different
from what they were 15 16 years ago
and we should recognize that this power
of iran whether you look at
syria yemen iraq
if you look at for example their support
of the most extreme groups in
palestinian politics rather
than support for a two-state solution
and peace on both sides
you know this is the nature of the
regime now really what i'm saying is 40
years on from the revolution
we've got to be clear-eyed about how we
we view this well being
clear-eyed about this as well though is
is recognizing that if we're serious
about trying to
tackle iran then we're effectively
siding with you know their rivals in the
region
saudi arabia some of our viewers as well
it's in the public domain maybe
questioning
the fact that the tony blair institute
has received money from
a group called media investment limited
close to the saudi regime they may think
that this is partly why you're talking
out about it
yeah but it's not the reason i speak
about these things is and i've spoken
about the power of iran for a long
period of time
is because there's nothing to do with
backing saudi versus iran i also think
by the way
looking at this thing in the prism of
shia versus sunni is also wrong
i mean the fact is there's one big
struggle across the middle east today
it's can the societies in the middle
east
where religion has been abused for a
long period of time
sunni and shia can those societies
become religiously tolerant can their
economies become rule-based
that's the central question and it's not
about whether it's you
back the sunni side versus the shia side
actually most of these countries for
example in the gulf have got significant
shia minority populations
the question is that islamist ideology
whether it's of the sunni version
muslim brotherhood through to isis the
shia version represented by the islamic
state of iran
the question is how do you defeat that
and end up with a region in which people
are educated to be open-minded
connected with the world and where their
economies can function on the basis of
rules and not corruption or cronyism
now just before we end the interview
there was one question that was quite
keen to ask you while i've got you with
us
and in your memoir you wrote i've always
been more interested
in religion than politics it's quite an
astonishing thing for a former prime
minister to say
what what did you mean by that well i
wasn't expecting that question yeah
bit of a curveball i just it's something
that i've been wondering
i think the place of faith in society is
really important and i think the
challenge you know i am really
interested in religion i'm interested in
studying different religions and
um i'm interested in whether it's
possible to reconcile
faith with the modern world now i think
it is but not on the basis of a religion
that is doctrinal or exclusivist um
and i think if faith departs from
society if we if we kind of say well
look that's just part of a
the old-fashioned way of looking at the
world i think it would be
if you lose the concept of faith from
society it's
tragic but i don't think you can
i think religion has no future unless it
understands
that it's got to be rooted in the modern
world
and the risk is you know faith operates
in two different ways in the world today
one is as a source of compassion
and a stimulus for progress in humanity
and the other is that this is my faith
and if you're not like me
then you're my enemy so these are the
two you know challenging i see this in
the middle east all the time of course
and and
yeah so i am i am fascinated by
by religion i'm also interested in
politics by the way
yeah well we've got that yeah do you
think it gives you something in common
with theresa may
i think it's important well well i guess
it looked
people of people who are of faith hold
that in common with each other
um and by the way you know i
it's really one of the things that i
think is really important about politics
um this is not necessary to do with
religion
you know you should be able to disagree
with someone in politics
without considering them either badly
motivated
evil or you know people you want nothing
to do with
and so when i have this complete
disagreement with theresa may over
brexit it doesn't mean to say i think
she's a bad person or badly motivated
have you spoken to us since she
became prime minister i have spoken to
her but not about brexit
um i mean i'd be perfectly happy dude by
the way but i think we probably
what about then about brexit what no
what what about what have you spoken to
her about
i think that should remain between us
but it wasn't about brexit okay
thank you very much thanks